that's how I felt when I went to my
first strip clubs
but see look at him I'mma break that
[__]
break that little
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys we have with us today Mr
Jesus
[Applause]
let's just talk let's just talk about
strip clubs dudes yeah it's about time
dude what do you guys want to know let
me unbuckle my [__] what do you think
of them have you ever been to one are
you going next week just stuff like that
after this conversation there's a thing
about strip clubs too you've never been
to one I've never been he's never been
never been we gotta go we gotta do a
[__] uh JK news Adventures to strip
clubs I don't want to go you know what
though yeah they all get in trouble
here's what I wished happened I wished
that I was still a virgin when I went to
a strip club what a bird yeah
because I think that well professional
is different from girlfriend right
obviously it's just a different thing
like yeah but then I think the magic
would have been much more stronger if I
were a virgin and I've never seen both
I've never seen any of that yeah I think
it would have blown my mind like oh my
God right but then we're not being like
high school or Junior High
how old were you when you went to the
first year 18-ish yeah around 18. 18 19
21. mine was like 18. never been nervous
I think I think I was like I think I was
like 30. oh [__] I didn't go to way
later the [__] is wrong with you bro
y'all we're not man in this [__] ing up
dude I'm a man bro I went when I was 15
years old whoa how did you get in well
we had fake IDs oh you're 15. that
mustache you really looked old and it
wasn't 18 and up Club it was like fully
nude though 18 and up is fully new yeah
that's the thing here because they don't
serve alcohol yeah 18 and up is fully
nude but 21 and over it's topless so in
case for those of you who don't know you
can't usually have both oh unless it's a
very special funny thing is topless is
still just a little string that's
holding it behind oh no no sometimes
they do a little like they do the whole
[__] the string and then they just go
[Laughter]
for Nick who's never been can you break
down the process of what it's like when
you go to a strip club
there's the vultures everywhere dude
horn dogs you walk in dude you get your
little section they sit you down the
girls [__] the the waiters are hotter
for some reason because they're clothed
and you're like
[Laughter]
who are you yeah it's just like foreign
but they're so hot so you're like thanks
um they're professional oh what do you
do besides this
you're too beautiful to work
[Laughter]
uh also have you ever considered being a
model but also you're sitting on my nut
so I can't breathe oh sorry yeah yeah
thank you so you're just like you're
sitting on my nuts they're gonna have
their tits in your face and you're just
like hi so at work I just do this this
is explaining what you do at work well
their tit is like on your [__] face
that's a strip club and on average how
much does it cost for a lap dance uh
usually it's like twenty dollars a song
but a song is like 30 seconds yeah they
[__] make it so fast they're they're
[__] you dude that's how they get you
on so you're like uh and they get those
nicers like it's two for one so two
songs for one but they play the song
even shorter yeah it's like yeah [__] so
they're getting chipped you're getting
dripped man all you're doing is like
legit like the way to dance also is like
[__] annoying show me on run they do
they do this they do I grab them and I
literally tell them like don't dance in
front get right here get to the come on
yeah yeah because what they do they
[__] stand in front of you and they
start just doing this again little
[__] dance are you just standing
there like come on like they don't see
that your cheeks right there you're just
like come on okay I'm gonna feel
something I can watch this at home did
they not motorboat do this [__] move
they go like this and they just I've
never had any of those and then they
just dance and they just go on your
chest just like like what are you what
does that do they air hump your chest
yeah they don't help your chest like
it's doing something and then they do
this hey when they do this grind where
they open their legs up and you just go
but there's this pocket
this is [__] like these you know this
pocket where nothing's touching
you're just getting your [__] legs
rubbed on the side you're like all right
this side [__] hurts actually
through my hip bone and they just got
their boobs and just go like this is
like okay cool but I'm not touching the
nipple so can you put me to the goddamn
nipples
so [__] annoying and then here's my
money like an idiot
so you go back to your seat like this
you're just like all right what's up
18 19 ish right
um and then so this is the Spearmint
Rhino right okay yeah first thing I walk
in and then my friends are like they're
all like experts at this time and I'm
like all right so what you got to do is
you gotta like you guys just say you
gotta be strong don't say no like the
first one that comes up to you you got
to say no and you gotta like look around
for the one that you really want and
then when she comes up to you then you
tell her come back during the two for
one special and I was like okay I'll do
that that's a good move good strategy
right and then like come on and then
what happened I didn't do that I didn't
do that at all no I didn't like there
was this one girl and I was like this is
when I fell in love with black beauties
because because my high school had a lot
of hot Mexican and black girls right
uh-huh and then but I didn't know like
the level of hot like this is like
professional hot right so I'm just like
you're not a high school girl like you
are you are like a college student
you're hot hot right and then so uh she
obviously saw me drooling mouth wide
open eyes like this so she was like
waving me and I didn't wave back because
I was like just shocked that a hot girl
was waving at me
she goes straight to my lap all that
stuff she's all like uh do you want to
party do you want to dance and I'm all
like I like those are different things
yeah like what does the party mean so so
I so so I was telling her like I was
like I was like yeah I like to dance
like I'm a dancer because I was getting
into break dancing and oh you're a
different dancing right yeah not knowing
she's like I don't want to break dance
with you
not knowing that she was asking me if I
would like a lap okay okay in a separate
place right and then my friend was there
and he went he was like no no no no like
we just wait and I'm all like oh I just
got here I'm gonna wait oh and then so I
was like but I wanted her and then he's
like no no just wait that's the first
one makes me go crazy dude girls love it
when you were here after a while you
[__] at the strip club one after
another like you get tired by the end of
the time at the you're just like no
ladies stop right like by the way end of
the night you're just like I can't I
can't do this anymore you're just
refusing girls left and right you're
just like I'm such a hot man yeah that's
that's you know that's cool
um so what's the party one what's that
well that was basically like a lap dance
like oh they're both flapping you know
that's not what they're thinking they're
thinking like [__] just want some money
yeah
you give me money or not you know and I
was like yeah I don't know and then the
show they do the show the floor show the
girls come out and candy right they do
the dance and then they have different
moves and then so and then afterwards
it's like you get to have lap dance with
the ones that are doing the shows the
one on stage one by one yeah they come
out they do the dance
and then it's like oh you know you want
that one the blonde one and it was my
other friend we had like a dual birthday
thingy cool he was there too he had a
[__] cast and then everyone was like
yeah it's his birthday and then these
two
um cougar white ladies go oh well you
get a two for one special and then he
was like I don't really want to go but
they pulled his ass over nice and then
the whole time he was like
because they were like we were like 18
19 they were like 40. oh that's what I'm
saying well maybe they were 30 but in
they looked like this yeah that's what
you can and that's me that's [__] up
they look like those cougars though like
like I mean everyone's like Jennifer
Coolidge yeah yeah yeah anyone that's
over 25 is a straight cougar but they
look like a cocktail waitress in Las
Vegas oh nice you know what I mean with
a super orange look yeah yeah let's see
the pink of their eyes like this it's
[__] sagging they were probably hot
like 10 years ago they're hot so the
most you ever did was just get lap
dances and well see I didn't know like
that most lap dances were like air humps
because like when I got it is she
[__] flipped over yeah had her [__]
in my face and told me to lick it oh
[__] okay well sir sir did you pay extra
no it was just 20 bucks
I did the whole thing I I found the girl
I was like oh I like this one a lot you
know
I was going to elac at the time oh I was
like we both we both go the same time
because then that sounds like a Nikolas
you say like college she was probably
bullshitting because I was like I've
never seen you on campus
so so I was like oh we got a connection
this and she's Latina she's [__] hot
oh yeah we're doing the whole like thing
she goes she straddles me immediately
grabs my hands
touch me in the butt and then she goes
I'm like I'm like this like what the
[__] twerking everything and then I'm
like God dang you're grinding on my dick
like crazy and she does this whole Jiu
Jitsu move she flips upside down her
[__]
um and then she goes lick kiss and I'm
like no no no
and I just went
it becomes a bop it yeah so that would
have been
[Laughter]
your experiences are very different
completely wow what the [__] the thing
is most experiences that I had at the
strip clubs it was like there was going
on
okay this is the experience there was
some kind of contact rubbish whatever
and they're telling you to do it my [__]
was my [__] was typically business and
then like but I actually don't like lap
dances more than seeing them on stage or
like buying lap dances for my friends
because I like to see her I don't like
to feel like them on me too close that's
the whole porn thing you're like into
porn you like this you're like watching
yeah put a piece of glass between you
and me I think it's like dude I'm not
like that it's your clothes I'm like now
I'm like a negotiator like I negotiate
them like they do that two for one like
um you know they're like oh it's 20
bucks I'm like a two for one and it's
like no just regular 20 I was like I
mean I'll do it if it's like two for one
you know and they're just like no well
we can't do that baby all right what
then because they don't want the twenty
dollars all right thanks I'm very like
straight to the point like I'm trying to
hustle that bro he's a businessman dude
I [__] I've done the whole thing
where it's just like oh
can we do like I'll give you 20 bucks
but me and him like you'll do it you'll
do one song because it's the two for one
dance right it's like two for one said
okay but that one song do it with him
then the next song just hop over and do
it to me
20 bucks and we're both getting the the
deal and she's just like I get what
you're doing but that's not how it works
it's kind of like well I'm just letting
you know like that's what we're gonna do
like if you guys want to do I'll just
find somebody Who's down to do it and
there's gonna be a [__] down to do it
so she knows that it's like [__] like
either I do it or this [__] does it and
it's like I guess I'm just doing the
[__] deal and I'm hustling them
they're like
I see them like [__] my homies are
getting left I'm slipping my [__]
foot in there
yeah dude I'll sit on his lap and you
dance on us
so who's experience would you rather
live
Jones [__] I want to live as experience
for your first one
I imagine in my head if I were to ever
go to a strip club it'd be like this
like it's awkward yeah I'd feel that way
yeah I mean I don't think I'd feel
comfortable at all like I don't think I
wish my experiences like it's like
rappers and black dudes I just walk in
and they're just like yo what up yeah
you know what I'm trying hey I got the
rubber bands and they [__] oh and
[__] oh oh and check this one out dudes
what [__] hey I went to the one
downtown Sans dude [__] black dudes
were just like I'm right next to them
they're just [__] up all this
confidence they're [__] all the girls
grinding he's just looking at that [__]
smacking her ass and [__] bad and I'm
like all right what's up okay I'm
learning I'm saying so then my turn
comes up and because she's like moving
sections and I go up there I threw like
what like maybe like five bucks and I
slapped her a lot and she's like she
grabbed my hands like don't [__]
smack me you don't [__] know me don't
[__] smack me and I'm just like but
he smacked you
like he's he smacked you
what the [__] the [__] this
[__] gotta go hell no
[Laughter]
hard enough they're regulars once you're
regular you kind of like feel trust they
know they know oh he gonna give me some
money I'm good with him he can like slap
he can touch but if newbies is like yo
yo just give me the you know what I mean
you keep it moving but I got fired up
they're over there I'm just like oh you
thought that's how you do it
hey
look at the [__] out of here man I
usually feel like I'm too respectful and
then I they make me feel like a little
[__] because I'm not doing too much so
like my experiences are always like I
I'm just like all right I'm gonna obey
obey the law and do one of these things
you know yeah and then like there's
always this feeling of you're not
[__] wanting me you know what the
[__]
[__] damn this is crazy you know like
that's a [__] ass in front of me this
is one time in uh Vegas where
I get this I'm getting this lap dance my
buddy pays for it I'm just sitting there
and then
she just spreads my legs because it's
too closed turns around butt right here
my hands are like here she grabs it
puts me on her boobs starts grinding
away and I'm like no wonder people like
strip clubs
you gotta either you tipping good or
something I never got that I don't I
just my friend paid that one and
maybe it was a good night are you going
on like Tuesday nights I know it's just
my library It's My Vibe My Vibe is very
uh I think Mexicans are [__] because
you got to be a confident black guy or a
shy Asian boy oh [__] you're stuck in
the middle
we're very
we're very YouTube YouTube
what's going on here yeah
Asian boy try that
how well is he doing oh you're looking
pretty good are you gonna shave you
gotta shave shave shave yeah like this
getting a little bit better yep that's
pretty good
[Laughter]
no hands
no you're crazy
[Laughter]
yeah yeah that would be that's what's
happening
that's how I felt when I went to uh my
first strip club
but she's like my [__] in his face they
look at him
break that mother
we're in New Orleans and then there's
this like really tall Asian chick that
was like super hot I was like oh [__]
she's coming over here yeah I was like
okay and then uh we just came from a
show so all everything was paid for oh
okay so they just came over to us and
then there was this like super hot Asian
stripper and like she did everything she
was like here here put her boobs in my
face and everything don't be so crashed
dude yeah can you not be so crashed and
then after like she sits down and
continues talking to me after her lap
dance you're like don't you gotta make
money why are you talking but I think
it's because of how we came in and who
brought us so it was all like there's a
little influence there yeah yeah yeah
yeah so so they were more inclined to
spend more time they just want you to
leave happy yeah basically so I thought
it was pretty even the special treatment
but the second time I went
um what was it it wasn't the same deal
so so we it was just me and like we just
cold wind yeah we just went out of
normal you know whatever and it didn't
feel the same and it felt actually way
more awkward and I was like yeah because
you're not catering to you as hard yeah
I don't think I'm gonna go to a strip
club unless it's like VIP yeah yeah
that's the only way dude because if
you're not there to like you know if
there's no purpose for you to be there
other than you know whatever you're just
scum at that point pretty much you're
the guy that goes in [__] silk sweats
dude I got so many pairs of those
perfect wear them all it reminds me of
like kind of going into like a
Vietnamese cafe Vibe where you see a
bunch of all right stop right there you
have been in Vietnamese cafe
[Laughter]
explain to him what you mean by
Vietnamese cafe think strip club uh they
do not serve alcohol they serve like
coffee and stuff wait wait wait wait
wait
Vietnamese
coffee yeah it's like Hooters but in
lingerie no sometimes they're naked they
wear
they were less than strip clubs
are you kidding me
and this is in America oh my God that's
in Orange County this one let me see my
picture here
sometimes they just wear like paint yeah
yeah sometimes it's not even close yeah
exactly oh boy
[Laughter]
he's still good are you a [__] kid
he's like [__] this video
let's go now he's emailing it to him
yeah that one's it that one's in Garden
Grove right
I mean I'm gonna be a [__] coffee
fanatic he's like I showed you Cafe Lou
yeah yeah
I don't just come in for the espresso
yes
[Laughter]
yeah how come you guys aren't there
doing this every day why are we filming
there I don't know I mean okay it's it
looks cool in pictures but then when you
actually show up sometimes it's kind of
like weird like there's just a bunch of
old hey my guy it's not weird dude
you're
getting a weird dude
I'll go under
the wind looking boxers just in my boxes
and [__] you guys are doing it I'm gonna
do it showing [__] chub dude that's
crazy and they just serve [__] drinks
I had a friend that worked there and she
said a lot of guys like are super weird
there because oh yeah
can you say something dude yeah yeah
you're in your underwear yeah dude that
that's you know
I mean
the best part is us not seeing the
picture is the reaction
foreign